معنى الان من بيكينا صحفيه سعاد ياشين هو
اهلا بك يا استاذه سعاد همم
عمدت الى الاعلان عن تخفيف جديد للقيود
المرتبطه بيكو في 19
من المدن بل في جده انحاء البلاد اين
تتجلى مظاهر هذا التخفيف وهي كانت قد
اعلنت في وقت السابق عن تخفيف في بعض
المدن الصبيح
صباح الخير ههه
تاثيراتها السلبيه على حياه اليوميه
للمواطنين الثانيين واعتقد ان ذلك يعني
مثل
همم
وجاء ذلك في سبب
من المواطنين
على رفع تدبيره اداره المقلقه للمجتمعات
السكنيه المناسبه لفتحها وسمعها تبي عدد
فتح ابواب المحلات التجاريه التي
كانت مغلقه بسبب تاثر من المصلين
لتحسين
في الوقت الحالي لا نحتاج الى نتائج
السلفيه
لمده 48 ساعه الاخيره في اختبارات الحمد
لله
تدبيره لمواجهه الوضع المتغيره والمغير
موافقه على مواضع ال همم الخاصه
لانها الدوله كبيره في السكان
شكرا جزيلا لك سيده سعاد شنو الصحفيه من
بكين